now this is a bit tricky but it's cool
so that's why i'm going to show you okay
here's our trapezium right we want to
work out the area i showed you one way
of doing it
i really like this way of doing it
because you because you can see
there's two parts to it and they're the
length and breadth of a rectangle and
we get rectangles okay but like i said
before you've got alternatives there are
lots of different ways to do it i
saw another three or four when i walked
around different ways maybe not as clear
but they still work okay let me show you
one other one that i like okay
here's a new trapezium you're going to
copy it down in a second right
i don't have to necessarily do all this
chopping and shifting and changing
if i can divide it up into shapes that i
do know the area of
right so for instance here's one way to
do it
if i join a diagonal like so
okay it's a bit wonky sorry about that
okay i don't have to draw that diagonal
i could have done the other one it would
have worked just
fine okay in fact i might even show you
that one as well because you're gonna
get the same result
what's the difference right well what
kind of shapes do i have
two triangles excellent and triangles
are good because i know how to do the
area of triangles
what's the area of each one well let's
have a look try this one
it looks the easiest right what two
pieces of information do you need to
know about a triangle
twerking good i've got a base right
there
i guess the height would be here right
okay but we already know what the height
of this whole trapezium is it's just we
just called it h
right so for this particular triangle
here
right area of triangle one
okay it's gonna be base
times height on two are you happy with
that
so far so good now when you have a look
at the other triangle the one that's
upside down
right what's the same about it well
it's the same height isn't it they're
both the same height it's just this
one's
flipped over what's its base
because i flipped it over the base is up
on the top here
right so if i do the area of triangle
two the upside down one
right it's going to be not b h on two
but a h on two now the trapezium
is both of those put together right so
the actual area
total area i should say is going to be
a h on 2 plus b
h on 2 but look think back remember when
we were doing algebra we looked at
factorizing
right the whole idea of factorizing is
to say look
i can take out a common factor here
right what are the common factors
the answer is there's an h and there's a
two an over
a division by two though so when you
take that out ta-da
what's left is the a plus b
and there's the same formula so what i'd
like you to do
is you've got just enough time to draw
yourself up a
new trapezium put that same diagonal
through so you get
two triangles and that's another way to
show the same result
which maybe you might prefer i don't
know just depends on you